fue un encuentro que se iba a dar el año
pasado pero precisamente por temas de
covid no se dio este es esta es la
primera vez que una el presidente
argentino kicherista se reúne en la casa
blanca con un mandatario estadounidense
después de que lo hiciera el kitchener
con el presidente el expresidente Bush
se habló de varios temas pero el tema
económico fue central sobre todo de Cara
a esta línea de crédito que quiere
Argentina para solventar la situación
económica que vive el país el presidente
Alberto Fernández le dijo que Argentina
en este momento cuando ocurre la guerra
en Ucrania y
las consecuencias de esta guerra están
derivando en menos alimentos Argentina
puede ser una opción para precisamente
ofrecerle al mundo más alimentos y más
energía y esos temas también se tocaron
en esta reunión bilateral después se
ofreció una rueda de prensa en la
Embajada Argentina donde varios líderes
y varios ministros que acompañaron
Alberto Fernández calificaron esta
reunión de positiva Bueno y por qué es
relevante el apoyo de Estados Unidos a
las negociaciones que tiene Argentina
con el fondo monetario internacional
ese relevante porque Estados Unidos es
el mayor accionista de el fondo
monetario internacional la decisión de
aprobar esta línea de crédito Este
programa de crédito de 44 mil millones
de dólares va a depender sobre todo del
visto bueno de la casa blanca y del
departamento del tesoro y precisamente
en esta reunión bilateral que tuvimos
que tuvo el equipo de gobierno de
Alberto Fernández con el equipo de
gobierno de Joe biden estaba presente
precisamente la secretaria del tesoro
también estaba el secretario de estado
Anthony blinquen personas claves para
probar y para empujar Este programa de
crédito de Argentina también hay de
Resaltar que Sergio massa el ministro de
economía de Argentina pues ya ha tenido
varias reuniones con altos líderes en el
fondo monetario internacional y este
viernes va a tener nuevamente otra
reunión con la segunda al mando del
fondo monetario internacional para
precisamente pues avanzar con este
programa de crédito que inicialmente fue
aprobado en el 2022 pero que no se ha
terminado de confirmar Esta visita tuvo
como telón de fondo la atención entre el
senado republicano y la vicepresidenta
Argentina Cristina Fernández A qué se
debe este choque
a los escándalos de corrupción que tiene
Cristina Fernández en Argentina y
precisamente antes de esta reunión
bilateral Ted Cruz que recordemos fue
candidato presidencial republicano que
es senador por el estado de Texas y hace
parte del comité de relaciones
exteriores pues publicó precisamente una
nota donde cuestionaba
estos escándalos de corrupción de
Cristina Fernández de Y además le pedía
a la casa blanca que investigara estos
escándalos de corrupción como lo ha
hecho con otros países entre ellos
recientemente Paraguay donde sus líderes
de ese país pues están siendo
investigados en Estados Unidos Entonces
le pedía la Casa Blanca directamente que
pues no omitiera el caso de corrupción
que se le acusa a Cristina Fernández en
Argentina y a otros cuatro funcionarios
entre ellos el hijo de Cristina
Fernández de kitcher Cristina respondió
en su cuenta de Twitter diciendo que
esto era un plan que esto ya venía de
alguna articulado porque cinco días
antes del atentado que sufrió Cristina
en Argentina ether Cruz este republicano
había dicho y le había pedido también al
congreso que sancionara a Cristina
Fernández entonces reaccionó diciendo
que pues esto era de alguna forma
sugiriendo como si fuera un plan en
contra de ella y posicionándose como
víctima pero pues eso se quedó de forma
paralela porque pues el equipo de
gobierno de Alberto Fernández dijo que
la visita en general ha sido muy
positiva Y seguirán acá precisamente
tratando de avanzar en este programa
crediticio con el fondo monetario
internacional